hey guys happy holidays happy vlogmas I
know I have failed at vlogmas the one
thing that I haven't failed is it's a
new tradition that Jenna and I have
started last year so we went and we
bought a bunch of toys last year for
Toys for Tots and this year I was really
excited so like Jenna we got to do this
again well great news because this video
is now sponsored by downsizing the movie
by Paramount now instead of doing like a
normal sponsored video where they give
you money to make a video I said Jenna
let's take that money and let's go and
buy a bunch of toys for the kids I'm so
excited because it's so much fun we get
to pick out all of these cool things and
then we get to donate them and then they
get I had so much fun last year it was
great ed came with us last year we were
like raiding Walmart like just going
crazy and going absolutely nuts still
many joy we did this year we're gonna go
to Toys R Us because what better place
to go for toys that Toys R Us they also
have a drop off donation there at the
store so it's super easy get the toys
drop them off so once again a huge thank
you to paramount and downsizing the
movie which is out December 22nd i we
saw the trailer the other day in the
theater and we're like we have to see
this movie see it we definitely will
Matt Damon is the Nick Kristen Wiig
isn't it I absolutely love Kristen Wiig
she is probably one of my favorite
actresses recently the whole concept of
downsizing and especially watching this
movie I felt like it was reflecting a
lot on that because this past year I
donated so many things I went through my
entire closet and went there all my
electronics and all of my gadgets and
donated so much of it to Goodwill
Salvation Army and there was some other
donation centers are on La that I
donated everything to and
pretty awesome I know Jenna she is like
the donating queen I mean donating a lot
of sexual it feels good most pizza to
get rid and to give back
I made Jenna help me do all the donation
and sorting through all of my stuff
throughout my closet and it took us like
almost a week to get through everything
but it was great because you know but
everything that we're donating is going
to a good cause
anyway let's start this vlog the movies
out December 22nd I'll put a link in the
description or you guys can check out
the film to get tickets and also I'll
put some links down there as well if you
want to donate to some charities for the
holidays so Jen do you know what this
means let's go shopping let's go I like
it look at this this looks fun come on
she's cute look at him he hops any
models I like that
oh yeah anyone ever playing like a
little Lego game here charm you see how
much make you fit let's see what awesome
so you guys know I'm a big fan of Lego
so let's go
[Music]
emojis where are those with the unicorn
and legs or anything
I guess cheeseburger sucks yeah show you
two cards I look good Jam set the
toaster maybe I need to get two cards
this is the walking gingerbread just
like the walking Delmonico's we gotta
get a hot dog
this is gonna be a good
good singing deck the halls' a fairy
wand yes
those look like easy little simple fun
gift look trading cards they still like
fidget spinners they don't know do they
high quality yeah put it on now let's
get to to fish people oh oh these are
not sleeping oh that was not no that's
not right
oh my gosh I'm like I'm shopping for
things that like I like I'm super
excited about look at all this space
[Music]
go grab another cart and then we can
check out for Indians 20 minutes
we've got cart number two I think this
time I want to get like super the
reading material I gave you some crafts
generation to get craft
[Music]
force was here hello these are like some
of my favorite games a little do you
remember playing scam no oh maybe
because I was too young
true I'm gonna get that because this is
a childhood game of my favorite there's
a lot of kids are here
Oh books wait a minute on the night you
were born
hmm is this like an instructional book
is it like a picture how - not for
children right you're born to move okay
hmm maybe let that one yeah we'll sit
look let's all just fine well yeah let's
talk wait
it's but you gotta press the button here
the word educational educational
learning love it
good night stinky yes
[Music]
oh the noise e46 sounds man come on
across one wait keep going what on
there's more no there's not
why we must get it craft supplies and
see what else we can get I would have
loved this when I was little I loved
puns and drawing it's a lot of pens so
this is definitely something that my mom
our mom same mom would've got me art
solutions I think that's fun bouncing
make them move
not the song about to make a move if you
don't I also make a booty booty hmm
create pixel weapons
shark shark baby sasquatch no one
thought to look at toys-r-us they didn't
but I found him let's meet ya yolks
carry well by one give them 40% off so
we might as well get another one
oh you're right I thought that was glass
she get
it's a $17 ball that's expensive
think we can get something great cooler
for that yeah likes $17
[Music]
this was me when I was little I wanted
to be a magician I hope they buy this
for somebody and they pursue their
dreams of wanting to be a magician and
may actually become one because I did it
Oh shadow game I think we're just about
fools
three minutes three minutes okay let's
go
think we're pretty much done we've got
two cards this one is just about full
do you see anything else wrap field and
then we'll go to the checkout
I'm so excited we've got a lot of good
stuff these are the mini hot balls we
gotta get numbers bringing me out is not
gonna be excited I gotta get my other
car I'm gonna push both those cards just
now watch me I'm watchin these shark
hills could hit this lady
as I could probably help I got it
it's over there it's really fool
[Music]
yeah I think this is good we can just
leave him here
a lot of them I know we filled up their
entire things we got so many great toys
so huge thank you to John for helping me
they are shouting I love it this is like
our new holiday tradition a huge thank
you also to downsizing in paramount for
sponsoring this video and for helping us
make some dreams come true for some kids
this holiday season I hope you guys are
having an amazing holiday I love you
guys and I will see you soon happy
vlogmas bye
[Music]